[Music]
for a show that has its characters
crashing through the crowded halls and
dodging girls like ping pong balls it's
shocking to think that some scenes would
be too bizarre for viewers well we found
some scenes from loud house that are so
nuts they had to be cut from the show
stay tuned until the end to see the
grossest craziest deleted loud house
scene of all time want to stay in the
loop with our newest videos hit that
notification bell and click the thumbs
up button below now let's get to the 10
most bizarre scenes deleted from loud
house shook eyes aren't gonna believe
some of these Lin brushing her teeth in
the episode linner takes off lincoln
points out that lin is way too
competitive during family game nights
she wins every game they play and then
she does terrible things to gloat about
her win she flips game boards dances on
the table shouting Leonard Leonard
chicken dinner she's pretty much the
queen of gloat the game gets pretty
tired of Lynn being so full of herself
so they play a game they know she can't
win called Settlers of catland
she inevitably loses and that's when
things get really bad Lynn becomes
obsessed with reclaiming her undefeated
status in the house so she competes with
the loud kids about everything one of
the things she turns into a competition
is brushing her teeth
in the final episode Lynn brushes her
teeth so hard a tooth pops out but in an
earlier deleted scene according to a
storyboard Lynn brushes her teeth so
hard it causes her gums to bleed it's
unclear why they deleted this scene as a
fellow youtuber pointed out there are
lots of scenes where Clyde gets a bloody
nose every time he sees Laurie so it's
clear that they have no problem with
blood maybe they thought the scene
crossed the line so they went with a
tooth falling out instead backed into a
corner when you've got ten sisters it
can be hard to get any attention to
yourself
that's how Lincoln felt in the episode
titled attention-deficit in this episode
Lincoln is trying to get his parents to
help him with a volcano he's making for
a school project the Lincoln's parents
are preoccupied with all of his sisters
so he winds up going to school with a
sloppy subpar volcano when Lincoln sees
Clyde's nice neat volcano he compliments
it Clyde tells Lincoln that his dad
helped him and offers for his dad's to
help Lincoln as well so Lincoln goes
over to Clyde's place
he's totally blown away with how much
attention he gets from Clyde stats when
Lincoln goes back home he shares with
his sister Lynne how great it is at the
McBride's house Lynne decides to go see
for herself
well eventually word gets around that
Clyde's house is the place to be
it must've driven Howard and Harold nuts
because they send them all home but
there is a scene that was deleted that
showed the sisters backing Clyde's dads
into a corner begging for attention it
must have been cut for time but it
clearly demonstrates how desperate
Clyde's dads were for some peace and
quiet making the grade in the episode
titled making the grade Lisa leaves her
kindergarten class and joins Lincoln's
fifth-grade class when Lincoln asks Lisa
why she's invading his class she tells
him that kindergarten is too much of a
waste of time well it turns out Lisa
doesn't fit in so well with her fifth
grade classmates she causes quite a
disruption which threatens Lincoln's
popularity in school so Lincoln
convinces Lisa to be more like the other
kids Lisa decides this would be a good
sociological challenge so she agrees to
act like an average student
Lisa ditches her glasses gets rid of her
science equipment and puts boyband
posters up in her bedroom she totally
dumbs herself down which causes a lot of
problems in the loud house they all
really depend on Lisa's genius abilities
to help them out Lincoln finally
convinces Lisa to be her normal self and
go back to kindergarten
Lisa agrees but there is a deleted scene
where Lisa changes from her average self
back to her genius self she rips off the
pieces of her new look and puts her
glasses back on they probably cut that
for time as well but Lisa does make it
back to kindergarten deleted April
Fool's prank in April Fool's rules the
family is terrorized by Louann on April
Fool's Day every year Louann becomes a
crazy prank monster and performs the
most epic pranks of all time on our
siblings and parents and this year is no
exception Louann unleashes the most
hilarious
most destructive most humiliating pranks
ever on the loud family there are so
many pranks in this episode you really
start to feel sorry for Lincoln and the
other sisters but there was an extra
prank that got high
because it made the episode too long
according to the storyboards Lincoln
wakes up in the morning to find that
LuAnn has lined his entire floor with
cups full of water in order for him to
get out of his room he has to drink all
the cups of water when he finally makes
it to his door he discovers that the
hallway is also filled with cups of
water he has to drink those too by the
time he gets to the end of the hall
he obviously has to use the bathroom but
when he grabs the doorknob it breaks off
in his hand
LuAnn ziplines in and lasted him it's
funny but ultimately he didn't make the
final episode more deleted pranks there
are a couple more pranks that were
deleted from April Fool's rules luan
really brings the pain in this episode
for real
this girl is relentless in this deleted
prank scene Clyde is the victim of
Luann's antics the storyboards show
Clyde walking up the steps to the loud
house collides foot trips a wire that
makes the sprinkler spray him then the
sprinkler turns on a leaf blower which
blows a bunch of hay on the Clyde or
whatever that stuff is the hay sticks to
his soaked body then LuAnn unleashes the
crows on him the crows swoop down and
attack poor Clyde then there's another
deleted scene where a clearly distressed
Lincoln is inside looking at a blueprint
of the house he runs upstairs and it
cuts to a wide shot of the outside of
the house there's all this commotion and
then from an even wider shot we see a
huge explosion coming from the house
it's not clear what the prank was that
caused the explosion but it must have
been something pretty major we'll
probably never know because that scene
ended up on the cutting room floor what
was your favorite prank from that
episode tell us in the comments
leni cries for Donnie in the loud house
episode titled lock and loud the kids
get in trouble for not locking the door
at night Lynne senior warns the kids
that there could be a burglar in the
neighborhood so they must keep the doors
locked at night then Lynne tries to
teach Lenny and Lola how to defend
themselves against a life-sized burglar
doll but it doesn't work because Lenny
starts flirting with the doll she even
takes a selfie with it later in the
episode Lincoln and Clyde learned from
the police scanner that the burglar has
been caught
Lincoln shouts down the hallway the news
of the burglars capture than all the
siblings cheer in the hall
well everyone except for Lenny hmm
adorably clueless Lenny she looks at the
selfies she took with the burglar doll
who she calls Donny and says that they
should have run off to Mexico when they
had the chance and here is where a scene
was deleted the storyboards show Lenny
shedding a tear on her phone looking at
the selfie of her and Donny the tears
flashes down on the picture of the happy
couple but this scene didn't make the
cut
maybe that extra moment slowed the
momentum of the episode Lily punches her
hand in the same episode where the loud
kids are worried about a burglar they go
to great lengths to protect themselves
we know that Lynne tries to teach Lenny
and Lola how to defend themselves from
Donny the burglar doll but they also
take other precautions
Lincoln's sisters run and stashed their
prized possessions in the bathroom when
Lincoln asks why they're choosing the
bathroom as the prime hiding spot Lisa
reveals that she's had cameras installed
in the bathroom since last year well
Lisa's not cool that's just downright
gross then Lana dresses up as a burglar
to try to teach their dog Charles to be
a vicious guard dog but Charles is
laziness gets in the way it seems to be
pretty obvious that the loud kids are
capable of defending themselves against
any unwitting burglar who might make the
mistake of invading their house even the
baby seems tough and intimidating in the
story boards little Lily is seen
slamming her fists into her other baby
hand as if to say she's ready for a
fight we don't know about you guys but
we're pretty sure we wouldn't want to
mess with that baby in the end the only
one trying to break into the house was
Lindsey near Co figure fandom panes
there's an episode called fandom panes
where it's revealed that Lucy loves
watching a show called the vampire's
melancholia Lucy takes her private
viewing time of this show very seriously
she even cuddled up to a bust of her
favorite character from the show
Edwin but Lucy's sisters ruined it all
when they burst in and insist on
watching the show with her they have a
crush on Blake Bradley his character
name is Tristan let's just say Lucy is
less than thrilled at her sister's
invading her private vampire time so she
tries to convince them to stop watching
the show but nothing works if anything
Lucy just fueled their love for the show
which is becoming more shallow because
of Tristan's presence
she decides the best way to get things
back to normal is to get people to sign
a petition calling for Tristan's removal
from the show this is where the deleted
scene would have been someone got a hold
of a picture of the script and it shows
the missing scene in the scene Lucy and
her
morticians club friends are protesting
outside the local news station with
signs they're chanting the bro must go
apparently
that scene had to go to strict this is
the most fun loud house deleted scene
we've found and we had to share it with
you guys in this episode appropriately
titled tricked it's Halloween and
Lincoln and Clyde have a plan to score
some major candy they share a dream of
getting full-sized candy bars to
maximize their trick-or-treating efforts
so they decide to go to a fancy
neighborhood where the good stuff is
they skip the part where Lincoln and
Clyde actually get the large candy bars
and cut right to them walking down the
street with bags full of candy the scene
they deleted is pretty awesome they
knock on the door at an estate in
Huntington Manor and a woman answers she
offers them a tray of bite-sized pieces
of candy
the boys are disappointed at first then
the fancy lady tells them that those are
the sample sized candies once they pick
their favorites she'll give them the
full-size candies then a heavenly choir
sings as the boys rejoice in hitting the
candy jackpot a butler rolls out an
entire cart of candy and throws confetti
on them as they celebrate the scene is
really funny it's a shame they had to
cut it from the episode fool me twice
we've got another totally inappropriate
deleted scene from the show's third
April Fool's episode named fool me twice
this time the loud family tries to avoid
Lou hands obnoxious pranks by going in
disguise and hiring stunt doubles as the
family hides in the garage the stunt
doubles go in the house and pretend to
be the family but nothing happens to
them that's because luan knew all along
that they hired stunt doubles it turns
out she has a diabolical plan to prank
them even worse than ever before but
before that happens there was apparently
a deleted scene in which Clyde was
disguised as an old man in a wheelchair
he appears to be spying on Luanne
but here's the totally gross part Clyde
was relieving himself in a bag while he
was spying see that yellow liquid by his
leg if Miguel puga posted the storyboard
on his tumblr site
he said the scene was removed for
obvious reasons yeah we can definitely
understand why they didn't put that
scene in the episode what's your
favorite deleted scene from the loud
house did we miss a cutscene that you
feel should have made this list if so
let us know in the comments and those
were the most bizarre deleted scenes we
found from loud house thanks for
checking it out deuces
[Music]